what's up guys it's a new year i'm on
the road it's been a while please come
out and see me everything on
savolcanocomedy.com as far as tickets go
i'm gonna be in san diego i'm gonna be
in los angeles uh burlington vermont uh
foxwoods and then uh further into
february detroit we have two shows on
february 11th pittsburgh two shows on
february 12th albany two shows on
february 18th tysons virginia were there
on the 19th two shows in madison on
february 26th two shows at the vic in
chicago i'm so excited about that on
february 27th right now chrissy d and i
will also be at the ryman auditorium in
nashville on march 11th i am going to be
adding dates and cities all the time all
on salvocanocomedy.com i've been having
a blast on the road i'm excited to come
see you guys go to the website check me
out i'll see you soon
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but
taste
how long has it been since i've been
able to say this to our fine audience
welcome to the taste buds podcast i'm
joe i'm sal
and we are the
t-a-s-t-e
buds oh man it's been um it's been four
reps i know dude
good to see you man you're an
entrepreneur now it's eon shark tank
you came back you come back with a knit
hat
i feel like you're a character from the
movie singles
i mean it's that's a fair that's a fair
roast
that's a fair roast
dude it's
what is it 17 degrees outside yeah i'm
not exaggerating no it is i believe i
think it's 17 degrees i took the shirt
out of the closet i'm being honest the
collar is annoying me with the back of
my hair
i don't know if i'm going to be able to
reconcile it no it's the whole collar
here cause i got that i got that seven
face we'll play a hammer stand and we'll
pull down yeah
we'll do a pull down maybe that'll work
there you go maybe we'll see what
happens yeah don't look at that no no
it's no it's it's not good living with
how i live
it's not good living how i live yeah and
then we're not good for each other i
don't think i don't know maybe we are
maybe we're not it's a weird it's a
weird
like i can't tell if you and i together
is is positive like more like a support
group vibe or if it's negative more like
a an enabling vibe it probably
flip-flops
depending on the day our moods
there's been days where i'm not sure
you'd say the same there's been days
where i need my dose of you you help me
get through and what i need and there's
been days where i'm like all right well
that just contributed to what i was
feeling and made it worse
so listen
how were things with q
while i was going hugh was
hats off to q round of applause to queue
nobly on the fly with jet over here when
we found out if you were tied up and
he
the intent was to spread those out yeah
but then you got a little busy and um
that's okay for now i guess if you can
move it so that the i mean this is well
i'm i'm on a high alert i'm on
heightened i'm heightened all right all
right i got a lot of stuff's going on
yeah all right
yeah if you could turn it so that the uh
stem of the thing is facing pimp
like almost like 12 o'clock noon no no
no sorry sorry this the the the handle
that i mean the the spoon the spoon yeah
like the how that comes out if you
couldn't 12 o'clock at pimp see now
that's bothering me i don't like is it
right that's fine leave it okay leave it
i really prefer nothing sticking out
what went on in this room while i've
been away
i prefer nothing sticking out of the
drinks if i'm being completely honest
listen i know that but i know how much
else uh that you you love this carpet
you've scolded me before to get anything
on the carpet you've scolded me for
putting things on the table bear what
are you doing there though
you got a tea with honey in it you can
see what honey okay so the honey's going
to settle always keep settling you're
going to keep needing to start yeah you
stir continually
honestly
out of the way and then
i'm probably done stirring i have
nothing to put it on the table with and
i know how you get about this table
that's fair that's fair so
you know you gotta you're an interesting
guy because you're particular but you're
particular in many ways
so one particularity is is outweighing
and competing against another i mean i
don't know what to do i thought of the
cup i was doing you a favor i almost put
a peanut butter spoon down this once i
thought you were going to have a stroke
that's that's that's uh come on
i hate a wet spoon
you want to put a wet spoon on a wood
table are you nuts yeah but i've learned
recently this isn't
so it's an applique on top
it appears to be real wood then i was
very upset when i saw one of the top
pieces curling and i realized it was
just made to look like i'm sure there's
a piece of plywood under there mm-hmm
but well yeah i'll tell you what's
telling me to tell you you sold me a
bill of goods here i thought this was
different kinds of wood
as a new bar owner yeah i could tell you
this too yeah
moisture is no good for an applique
either yeah i know you don't want that
she's not good for anything actually
moisture is a problem yeah it really is
a prob
uh cue i mean q pimp has uh googled uh
ocd when it was first discovered 1868
that's it i thought it was older than
that but i mean i guess it is older than
that it's older since the dawn of man
right right right but i guess up until
1868 everybody was more worried about
syphilis
prior to 1868 nobody went
[ __ ] is your problem
right
right
right it wasn't until 1868 that some
very proper man said to another proper
man it's called oh my god i never saw
call this scroll back up him it's also
referred to as questioning illness oh we
got that oh my god that is that i
question if i have the illness
that is a great
i want i want merchant's questioning
illness you know people say like i have
ocd
but like it's thrown around yes but like
when you actually have it
it's so bad no i know it's brutal
it's brutal yeah i i'm finding as i get
older i don't think i necessarily have
hdd i have a anal retentiveness
let me ask you a question that
terminology i never understood it
yes
it feels so weird to me that it's
become such a
common thing people say
that people can announce
that they're anal
and like every time someone does that
i'm like i i i i don't like the
connection still no i hear you you know
you hear anyone saying all walks of life
ages people oh i'm very anal well anal's
got a different there's a secondary term
obviously right to it that makes you
uncomfortable anally retentive it's a
okay so is freud's typically odd
proposition
was that don't you love how google just
dismisses sigmund freud completely one
of the great minds of of the last two
centuries freud's typically odd
proposition okay was that children in
the anal phase start trying to exert
control over something they've created
their poop
because that's what i was wondering it
says
uh it comes from that anal comes from
analog attentive which we knew uh which
literally literally describes childlike
behavior of not wanting to release one's
bowels to defecate
yeah like i'm anal i don't want to make
a mess i guess like i'm anally retentive
i mean i'm anti-defecation
defecation
so it's basically well no that would
that would make sense because anal is
remember the anal retentive chef he'd
like wrap up the trash in saran wrap
yeah what is that put it in the bag and
stable it but what does that have to do
with his bowels it's it's overly it's
overly uh neat and controlling and you
know well that but also it can be overly
neat and overly germ safe and you know
what i mean so you think that kids
didn't want to release defecate because
they would that's the connection i think
i'm making thereby defying the pair
where he wants to read from pimpy
right here
why it's uh
a phase of the anal stage in which
pleasure is obtained by retaining feces
i'm sorry kids earmuffs
thereby defying the
parent and in which the sadistic
instinct is linked to possession and
control of the okay so control
it's supposed to be against your parents
i guess yeah i mean that makes sense to
me
but then the etymology there every time
you say i'm anal retentive is i'm like a
child
trying to hold back feces for pleasure
to define my parents and maintain
control of my ex
in a literal sense but that's like
that's like saying everything that [ __ ]
on daytime tv yeah but that's like
saying every time you say booty you're
referring to pirate treasure you know
what i mean like words evolve eventually
and
yeah but anally retentive still means
the same thing
it's steeped in that okay didn't he make
everything about an excrement
he made everything about parents yeah
very much yeah yeah he sigmund freud
came up with oedipus complex i believe
right that's right yeah he was also a
cokehead
he was
he was you know this picture like
him coked up and really telling all of
his ideas to his friends who just roll
their eyes because they're like he's
getting his coke ideas again but
meanwhile they were really genius ideas
but nobody listened to him back in the
day he's like dude i got this new thing
it's called it's from the time when coke
was acceptable it's like when was that
well when they used to put it into
coca-cola like coke was not illegal at
one point what are we talking about here
what are we talking what are we talking
about there was a time when cocaine was
not illegal when they used to put it in
coca-cola yeah coke was in coca-cola
when it first came out that's what it
was called i swear to god that's why it
was called coke joe derosa
if this is real
soda what
like pure insanity
once contained the drug but much likely
less
than the pu than a post claim how is
this even [ __ ] possible i never heard
of this
i can't believe you never heard of this
before
it says here the first bottle of
coca-cola contained three grams of
cocaine
3.5 that's enough to kill you
wait i'm sorry coca-cola the soda that
they sold in stores two kids and yeah
had cocaine in it yeah cocaine at one
point was not illegal in this country as
far as i know or it was at least in a
beverage or it was at least socially
acceptable don't forget it comes from
the cocoa plant it was much more pure it
was not you know what i mean it comes
from the cocoa plant yeah you're not you
weren't dealing with the [ __ ] you're
dealing with today i didn't i don't
really know much about cocaine i
realized
eric clapton wrote a good one about it
it's not his song by the way it's a
cover okay yeah i also like i didn't
know remember that song i'm in love with
the coco oh yeah yeah i thought that guy
just liked a really nice cup of cocoa oh
and yeah i i found out i found out later
that it meant cocaine i was like
remember uh she likes the cocaine she
likes the cocaine
she likes it what was that song i don't
know was that buck cherry she likes the
coke cage
you look like someone from buck cherry
right now
yeah there it is she likes to i don't
know i don't know
oh by the way you know what i originally
thought i'm in love with the coco is
that he liked the dark skinned gal i
don't know that song
oh that's what i did for trash but go
back to that
pimp looked it up
dr uh cocaine was not made illegal until
1920.
so you're freud's pre-20
there's a child
he's got a nickel to spare
it's 1940s he walks into a soda shop a
candy store no but it's illegal at this
point okay in 1919 right this guy's got
a penny you're telling me a kid walked
into a neighborhood grocer bought
a bottle of coca-cola classic and it was
called coke because of the coke it might
have been considered more of an adult
beverage back then that i don't know
coca-cola doesn't the coca-cola refer
like the cocoa
cocaine comes from yeah i understand
they both come from the same place but
them naming coca-cola was not
indicative of oh there's cocaine it was
we just looked it up like it's cocaine
cola we just looked it up no but like
maybe it's because it's from the coca
plant
listen to me
coco coco listen to me american
pharmacist john smith pemberton founded
coca-cola in 1886 beverly concoction of
cocaine and sugary syrup there you go
what
what is going on
coca-cola first sold at racially
segregated soda fountains i mean
you're talking like everything they were
doing in 1909 was on the up i mean there
was a lot of bad [ __ ] happening back in
1909 in this country this is the least
of the problems from back then i'm not
sure it is i feel like i mean we haven't
even gotten into the battle and we i
think the issue is they were giving the
cocaine-laced ones to the poor
neighborhoods
okay
in 1899 coca-cola began selling its
drink in bottles
the lower classes and minorities now had
access to the cocaine infused tonic why
now they didn't have it before maybe
they just did the maybe they didn't
before i don't know
cocaine from its product in 1903. so
there was
what year did you motivated by racial
bias and tightening regulations
what i mean this sorted coca-cola pass
does not follow it anywhere right now
they got they got two polar bears
slapping each other around in the bushes
like that's what they do they got they
got clydesdales and polar bears like
shoving each other around in the snow
yeah and it's like it's americana yeah
it's american yeah yeah it's like
budweiser oh no i'm thinking of
budweiser for the clydesdales but yeah
but it is americanah
yeah i i i'm sorry my my my balls i mean
america i don't know if you know this
got blown off i don't know if you know
this album we got off to a rocky start
in this car i understand that you know
baseball's americana go back and look at
baseball's practices back
in the pre-40s what would they do they
were racist what did they do a black guy
didn't play in baseball until hank aaron
oh that i i thought you talked about
something more in the 60s i thought you
were something more obscure or jackie
robinson excuse me in the 60s the uh the
what did hank hancock's favorites
because he broke babe ruth's record
that's what hank aaron's claiming jackie
robinson was the first black baseball
player in the 60s baseball's americana
still no no i get that you're right yeah
guns look at guns that's americana look
at how much damage guns have done yeah
i just find it i just can't believe that
cocaine
was put into a
a cold beverage that was sold in
neighborhood stores it just doesn't mean
how would people react when they drink a
coca-cola i don't know i mean that's why
they do say most most businesses we know
today were from the boom of 1999 to
1903. really yeah because people were
all coked up and thinking of ideas i
mean this is the thing man
you know you can knock you can knock the
uh
as i scratch my nose you cannot
the substance is all you want
i like people like 1902 alcohol helps
coffee helps this help people in 1902
are like i just got a coca-cola you want
to go into the bathroom
so
how we really sidetracked here how was
it with q
it
it was very nice for queue it was nice
we used to of course do a podcast called
what say you we haven't done a long time
and uh we're thinking about rekindling
that but it was nice but it was that
makes sense you should put more on your
plate
we that we had we had to have a a a
united nations style meeting to get this
recording session on the books today
yeah it was it was
start another podcast back up it was
more of like um
like spirited conversation right versus
that's like an element of what we do but
a lot of times we didn't go at each
other's throats
there was no popping of veins or
changing of skin hues right or anything
like that there was no the decibel
levels were maintained i watched i got
into a little bit of a little bit of a
back and forth but it didn't it didn't
achieve anything that we i watched
eclipse yeah and he really humors you
and i got news for you
that ends today oh
really
i'd like to see remember what mine and
q's um
ranks were because
obviously it won't count toward our
which by the way no i thought it did
count if somebody's
still lost he took the loss for you
but it we're the winner because then we
kind of we did you versus chris i don't
know i don't know if that one should
count okay i'm fine with saying that the
person subbing is you get this i don't
care either way i just feel like i took
a loss when i was subbing
or had a sub for you like i felt like my
loss to chris counted
and that means
if you got some wins i'd like to reap
the best we'll check it out but i also
want to know when is the date
that the season is like these these
these past today these win losses have
to be counted yeah but we negated to use
it in any meaningful way so we have to
reset that bar we have to move the goal
line or the goal
we can just say let's just do a tally on
february 1st and that's it
no that's arbitrary
because episode how about that
a season or maybe just 52 right 53.
you know we're passing we're past it
yeah well let's clip it there
right right but then oh so then we just
retro yeah we just we go back and we
prorate i guess our one year is during
christmas that we know i lost already we
know
100 i lost
yeah i was behind by like five like for
the last really yeah
i mean yeah i lost i'll take my
punishment like a man
i think what needs to happen is we need
to just set it a little further like not
like february 1st because february 1st
of february 1st means is in three weeks
which means you don't have then it
doesn't matter if you're behind more
than three episodes it doesn't matter
february first what i think we have to
do is set the number of episodes in
so that there's at least a little runway
for you to come back i set the
punishment and set the punishment ahead
of time so that we can build towards
something agree to what it is for either
of us beforehand instead of just saying
like on the 52nd week i had a better
record now let me tell you what you have
to do but we already said that we
already said it was going to be a year
tally we agreed on it it's just we
missed it because there was coveted
spikes and things got all wonky these
last few weeks that's why we never got
to do a christmas episode that's no
problem if you want to cut it off at 52
we'll get to 52
i say it's either that or we go or we
see on the 100th episode and we extend
100 that takes a little too long because
that's like another like three like
eight months
ups the antis a bit doesn't it yeah but
i don't know if we should wait make
people it's what do you think the number
is that we should do
i say if we're out where are we at now
what episodes we have now
let me check
if it's something like what 60 62
62
but that's not a number that means
anything no no no
oh
you're 69.
well where are we now fair enough where
are we now
where are we now we're at episode
okay so
69
that's our number i guess so ten more
episodes you to come back
yeah okay all right but we don't know
what you you could be down seven i don't
know doesn't matter okay so does it
matter
babe i'm trying to make it more fair to
you buddy i don't care i'll take the l
at 52. i don't care wow we agreed to it
we already agreed then let's go back to
52. we never said a punishment by the
way uh the the great gal and guy who
were fiddling around with that
spreadsheet in blue and yellow and like
somebody was doing it and somebody was
helping us update or correct it i don't
know where you've been lately i i you
might be around i would say can you can
you the world's the most updated it's
like you're on the world of stuff
guys we need the we need the most
updated spreadsheet the world is falling
apart the seams this is a mess
i know this is a mess i don't know
what's going i don't even know what
month it is doesn't mean taste buds has
to fall apart no i know get your act
together two people that will volunteer
on your own merits all right listen
we're already
we've got to get to the battle we're
going 20 minutes we're 20 minutes we got
to get to the battle
but
before we do
i just want to say officially the [ __ ]
is back
[Laughter]
play time is over all right that makes
me sigourney weaver and i am surprised i
am shocked
at how many people wrote to me and said
we miss the insanity
cue and sell together is very nice it's
very pleasant we love by the way i got a
bone to pick with q real quick all right
look at this keep going yeah
look at this
i do want to get to this battle
one of the best guys birthday versus
christmas one of the best guys i've ever
known yeah
that's not carried away yeah in recent
years
best guy you've met in atlanta yeah
you become closer than the last year
he's a good guy
people missed the commerce he's got a
real
response because he took some shots at
me when he was here and now it's time to
go back he defended you i know but he
also he just barely he had he decided to
a torching loss he had to say
in the tweet
this podcast is sponsored by better help
what's up taste buddies uh
talking about one of our favorite
sponsors betterhelp uh there's something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
uh i got my issues all lined up you guys
might think it's just peaches and cream
over here and i just have a very happy
podcast life but listen you never know
what anyone's going through you don't no
really uh you know like i i'm on you
know i'm on tv and stuff but [ __ ] i got
i got as much [ __ ] going down as as
anybody else you never know what
anyone's going through and so that's why
we like better help as a sponsor they
assess your needs and match you with a
licensed professional therapist uh can
be done quickly in under 48 hours it's
professional counseling it's done secure
online it's not like a crisis line
and because it's online you have a range
of experts everywhere that you might not
have in your local area
it is available worldwide you can go to
the betterhelp.com tastebuds and uh
check out their reviews um
well just betterhelp.com reviews check
out the reviews um there's testimonials
on there
and things like that a million people
have used better help so far uh and
they're recruiting even more councils in
all different states so if you are a
little hesitant about it uh i think that
the proof is there special offer for you
guys our listeners get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
tastebuds check it out that's 10 off at
betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com slash
taste buds
hellofresh what is it what is hellofresh
it's farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy and fun and affordable that's why
it's america's number one meal kit man
we know that
uh guys new year it's a new year you
might want to turn over a new leaf
prioritize some things maybe you want to
start eating better start stop ordering
so much take out maybe you want to learn
to cook maybe you want to get healthier
you're prioritizing your wellness
hellofresh has endless options of
cooking
to make at home cooking simple and
enjoyable they deliver those ingredients
to your door it's farm fresh stuff it
arrives within one week so it's
convenient and it doesn't skimp on the
quality
you can stop going to the grocery store
spending money on gas time is money i
learned that early on time is money
don't wait in long lines don't go out
and waste your time and don't order
excess food because it's pre-portioned
it's kind of all you actually need so
you will not be throwing away food you
won't be wasteful it is cheaper than
restaurants up to 72 percent cheaper
which is the same quality on average you
save 65 bucks a month when you order
from hello fresh instead of grocery
shopping it's a nice way to tighten that
purse string or that wallet
and save a little money where you didn't
even know you could right now i i use it
i've used it ever since we started um
and
i am not one to cook but i do cook now
that i use hellofresh and i always was
hesitant because i don't know anything
about the kitchen and i just was afraid
to either burn stuff down or i didn't
know the techniques but with hello fresh
it's simple directions and ingredients
and even i have become a cook uh go to
hellofresh.com right now slash
tastebuds16 to use the code
tastebuds16 for up to 16 free meals and
three free free gifts it's the best deal
in the biz we talk about all the time go
to hellofresh.com
tastebuds16 and then use the code
tastebuds16 for up to 16 free meals and
three free gifts hello fresh america's
number one meal kit a girl
texts me a fan she goes i'm so sorry i
never reached out after that poll about
you or chris i go what are you talking
about she goes were you okay with that
what do you mean we got you on the she
thought in the episode you were laughing
i thought so too no i am i was saying i
thought it was clear she apparently was
very worried about me
this kid's got a real problem with
text response timely text response yeah
oh if you're doing the if you're doing
the voices he doesn't do them i know but
i went back to regular text okay okay
right
he texted me
i said we we're overdue for a hang right
okay
he wrote back
he wrote back and wrote
um i cannot get covered for the next
month and a half or it'll [ __ ] the tv
show up i'm planning on locking down
life until mid-february but maybe that's
unrealistic i wrote back
it sounds stupid to me really stupid
right it doesn't respond did i write i
don't know how yeah we have to be real
careful that's why we tested yeah then i
wrote seriously though maybe we can do a
testing hang or something
doesn't respond to that right if not
let's just shoot for a wonderful
valentine's day doesn't respond to that
wow three
a number four goes in oh
i got an email yesterday the subject
line is why do we all hate q
i was like what the [ __ ]
then i realized it was from my star trek
newsletter and they were talking about
the character from the next generation
is the character named q yeah no he
didn't respond to that that's from
thursday at 12.
a legit b to p
right yeah you have a legit bone now
this is a guy is high a lot i know and
this is a guy
a lot no i know i know
look i've
i have sat with him
there's a man i've sat with over quiet
drinks
he i mean that's i mean that we've
expressed genuine love
[Music]
i know he has issues with the voice text
because he he's again he he'll listen to
it and forgot he listened to it then it
disappears and he forgot he had to you
know all that [ __ ]
i'm on taste buds right now with sal
reading the last four texts i've sent
you and both of us are flabbergasted
that you have failed to respond to any
of them period yeah
when you hit me with the third and then
the fourth it's hard to make an excuse
for
wait say that again i said you when you
hit me with the third i was like ooh but
then you're a fourth
i can't make an excuse
if i if i didn't know any better i would
imagine that that relationship soured
it does make you feel like that a little
bit doesn't it it does
doesn't it it does and i i'm sitting
here going
could he have been that mad that i said
it sounds stupid that you wanna oh
that's you now no no i know yeah
you'd think i'm the pothead
[ __ ] paranoid right now right
but uh should you just call him
you should you know what you should do
you should scare him you should do
something like bro i'm it's two o'clock
i've been it's two o'clock i've been
here since 1 30. what the hell
i don't think he's he's fatigued himself
into oblivion he's too confident a man
he's too confident
really i know many facets of him really
yeah we don't we're not we all have
facts i think he would just be like no
no of course but i think he'd just be
like he'd know you what are you talking
about man we never made that plan yeah
yeah like i don't think he would you
maybe got to get him at the right time
though i'd say if you hit him up with a
text like that around 9 00 p.m you're
sure [ __ ] gonna confuse you what to do
i'll tell you if you want to get used to
time's the right time to get q's goat
i'll tell you how to get q's go because
we all saw it at ac tell me can't play
two hands at once
yeah there was almost a brawl
in the private area
this calm no i i did it was that what
was the reason i thought that i had to
play like five hours he was like oh i
forgot to give you my card and the guy
was like i'm not taking it now story i
heard
the story i heard was
he was told by the pit boss he was not
allowed to play two hands
he said
i'm not playing two hands that's my
friend's hand they went to the bathroom
just now that's all
so just deal
he then got dealt a terrible hand and
then told the dealer that he did that on
purpose to sabotage him
uh because he
[Laughter]
oh really oh i heard that like after
playing for many many hours and losing a
lot of money he was like oh i forgot my
to give my casino card and they were
like well we can't do anything about
that now i could be wrong because that
was late into that i heard he
mike sternly were you not there for this
told the dealer that he had been set up
as revenge for trying to play two hands
for once oh that's hysterical yeah he's
q is excellent at in a scenario like
that at leveling accusations
in the best possible way he he he
definitely gets conspiratory is that the
right word even spiritual conspiracy yes
yes
all right but babe we've got to get into
this battle this isn't so let's go sorry
all right ready here we go
it feels good to be back in the shad
back in the set back in the sad
that's a really funny
that's a really funny phrase tagline for
this because sad because we're such sad
sex i love it but sad as in
short for saddle yeah but back in the
sad it's also back in the morning so we
spell it s-a-d-d
yeah i love it it's like sad and saddle
i love it yeah but what is that what is
that merch gonna be it's like merch for
when you came back oh look who it is
you think those were interesting
engaging texts
[Laughter]
that's an audio message i hope you
listen to this one because we're
laughing our balls off
oh god
oh man that's great
[Music]
dick we're me and kuana is what i mean
he's a confident man me and q are like a
if you want to call it a group chat a
three-way text chain for years with
chris jericho the wrestler yeah oh chris
jericho is another one it's all he knows
with all three of us just it's just
breaking balls the whole time and all it
is is like cutting snide remarks like
we'll volley back like in one day we'll
do like 15 of them then everyone here
for a month and then somebody will pick
up and then the whole day it's just like
ripping into each other love it that's
great yeah it's fun um all right babe we
got it we got to get let's do it
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you all right here
we go it's talking to those eyes again
it's time to
b a t t l e punch
is nice to look in the eyes again just
as awkward but it's nice
christmas versus birthdays chalice
christmas i am birthdays all right so
this is where we came up with this
obviously those are two
very huge holidays we don't think a
standard holiday can be christmas we
were always gonna put christmas up
against something christmas time came
and went we didn't and we're like no
problem we'll just use it in a more
general battle later and we said what
could go up against christmas
now there's one thing that is universal
to everyone and it's everyone has their
own special day
also
mind you i love when it's my my lady's
birthday i love when it's my parents
birthday i i love celebrating them i
love making them feel special getting
them gifts things like that so birthday
means that and birthday also means
yourself every year that one day of the
year that you're waiting to come around
that when you think back on your life
and i'm making i'm just making a case it
don't sound like i'm getting a case of a
birthday but i'm i just want to explain
why i thought it was a very good
match-up right when you think back on
your life it's not probably hard to
recall birthdays those are at the
forefront of memories
for the most part not all of them but
like you remember birthdays they're
they're a day that means something and
since everyone has that day recurring
just like christmas every year i think
birthday would be the second closest
holiday to be able to compete with the
ultimate beast by the way and no offense
to anybody that
doesn't celebrate christmas
sure who right now might be saying how
dare you we're speaking from experience
i can't do it yeah that's true that's
why we couldn't do hanukkah or whatever
we're saying this from the experience of
christmas celebrators and birthday
celebrators
i will say this
christmas
favorite holiday hands down
favorite time of year arguably
um
or if not definitely
uh but i also love birthdays you know i
go all out for the birthdays every year
you do you are a guy that does birthdays
they're always real great nights yes and
i remember your last few birthdays
because of it and i don't even remember
mine and i also am the guy that will
call you and say
what are we doing for your birthday
let's get it going emily you know also
i'm the guy whose full christmas decks
are still up right and i don't want to
be pressured into when i might take them
down yes so the side of my own time it's
an internal feeling that comes through
you got gifts under the tree like i
kissed some well because i i buy gifts
for so many people that i don't see them
oh you know it's interesting
for you no you don't actually for you
yours is yours is a little more
difficult it's gonna give you [ __ ]
no no i i actually i forgot about this
yours i don't you're i can't say much
about giving yours away so i don't want
to say much just that i can't give it to
you today and
but yours i actually had when we did the
hang at the bar
uh last week yeah when we and i and i
meant to bring it with me that night it
would have been a perfect night to bring
it was just right after i mean we're
opening it on the show right
oh my god do you want to do that yeah
okay it's not wrapped
okay it was meant to be wrapped but i
ran out of christmas paper so i went on
a hard target search i realized i didn't
get an excess paper
i just we bought two rolls of generic
like birthday
oh my god it's very apropos for this
episode i was wrapping you a christmas
gift in a birthday wrap
i had to wrap my christmas gifts this
year in birthday paper because
uh target ran out so it's downstairs i
just got two new rolls as a couple days
ago it slipped my mind to wrap it in
time but i didn't think i'd be giving to
you on the pod but i think
i think it's it's maybe in the next
week's pod
next week's next episode i'll give you
because we've already come in too much
here yeah yeah yeah oh that's fun i
should have bought it and i came home
and i was like
now i don't have a gift for you i didn't
know we were doing it let me tell you
something right now let me explain
something to you right now
i
understand how you feel i feel the same
way when it happens to me i'm someone of
the mind that if we didn't discuss they
were exchanging no harm no foul i may
have just as easily not gotten you guys
gifts it just so happened that i don't
hold back when i see something that i
think someone would like and if that
happens naturally i'm buying the gift i
don't care if you have a gift for me i
don't care if we spoke about it it
happened with both of you but i wasn't
like oh i'm gonna get them a gift and
hopefully they get me like i don't do
that i'm very similar there's certain
people every year
that are basically family where no
matter what i figure it out
but i'm the same way with friends hence
you're receiving that deluxe cheese
board in the middle of the year for no
apparently i believe you know what i
mean yeah i've exchanged christmas gifts
with big j for like the last
maybe four or five i don't even know
like this year i don't know if we are
just out of sight out of mind we haven't
and i didn't click with me that i didn't
see anything that really registered so
i'm just saying it's it's it's it's soft
and loose
your comedian friends are the best gift
giver
me either either of you guys well jay
has given me great gifts over the years
ari gives great gifts
ari i gotta say
sal is great
be a sal i wear like a badge of honor
it's very
yeah but it's very thoughtful and it's
always something very unique
um
and i don't want to get into specifics
but it's always safe to open this thing
i can't wait either i can't wait
thoughtful and very unique tune in next
week folks yeah
uh ari
has given me some crazy
[ __ ] like where it's like
you know it's it's it it's it's some
with a guy like you who's big hearted
and whatever
it's it's always beautiful beautiful
things not that i'm not that i'm caring
i have an enlarged heart yeah yeah i'm
gonna die soon but
don't take to take this the right way
it's not as surprising because you're
you're that spirit right ari great guy
don't get me wrong but ari's got a very
demonic side to him yeah yeah so when he
hands you something
and you can see the sincerity and
thoughtfulness in his eyes and you're
also like i never would have been able
to get yeah did you urinate on this or
something it kind of knocks you back a
little bit it really knocked well
because especially since didn't he
literally give a box of [ __ ] to big j he
did
legislation wrapped up
my point is yeah my point here's a guy
that'll literally give you a box of [ __ ]
but then also give you you know what
ari's great with he travels a lot and
he'll always come back with something
from his travels for me that's what i'm
saying yeah that's exactly what i'm
saying so that's also
his lovely lady as well who's just as
good a friend of mine she's very she's
she's an amazing gift giver because she
doesn't just
she makes things and gives it to you
like it comes from her mind and heart
and time and energy that's big the uh so
hey taste buddies we have a new sponsor
called ballsy and in case that didn't
insinuate what it's about it is about
your private area the man's private area
your ball area and keeping it up to
speed and on the up and up okay so for
me you know guys know me i am
cleanliness is next to godliness i
believe my cleanliness is a reflection
of myself especially in all the parts
that should be very very very [ __ ] and
span
um
i don't know what you use to clean i
don't know if you think you're a clean
person or a dirty person or what you do
what your routine is for below the belt
but balti's here to help uh you know
whatever makes you sweat if it's
exercising if it's the latest episode of
succession uh or whatever it is you
wanna make sure that you take care of it
that's why you gotta check out ballsy
they make men's products from man parts
um the groin area it's no secret that
the balls are prone to odor sweat and
irritation so upgrade your ball game
with ballsy they make quality
long-lasting products formulated to keep
you fresh comfortable and confident it's
things like deodorants ball washes they
have trimmers they have ball cologne i
mean the ball puns are off the charts
with these guys go on the website
ballwash.com just to laugh at all the
damn ball puns there are because there
are many you just scroll up a little bit
more too yeah no problem they got gift
sets if you want to choose that uh they
have a guarantee 200 000 satisfied
satisfied customers and a 30-day money
back guarantee so there's no reason not
to give ballsy a try whether you're the
guy who loves lawn work and drinking a
cold one in your man cave or you're
interested in self-care but don't want
to smell like cupcakes or flower
arrangements ballsy is for all guys who
want a great product to solve all your
ball needs notice when i say ball every
time i really hit it because i want to
really drive it home i say balls
no bs ingredients no sulfates parabens
synthetic dyes
no testing on animals um yeah i mean
we've gotten ballsy now in in in the
mail
i um i am gonna put it into my routine i
have not done it yet but joe derosa told
me that ballsy has changed his ball game
he told me he gives the big thumbs up on
it uh he i the ball cologne is not for
me he likes the ball cologne
but i do love all the washes and all
things like that not sure where to start
take the quiz get a customized system
tailored to your personal saturation oh
boy
um anyway here we go let's see
so here's the offer keep the funk off
your junk right now if you go to
ballwashballwash.com
tastebuds20 and put in promo code taste
buds 20 that's 2-0 you will receive 20
off that's 20
off plus free shipping when you go to
ball wash ball wash dot com slash
tastebuds 20 and put in the promo code
taste buds 20.
all right
fanduel ad
folks
giving a shout out to one of our
sponsors fanduel
fanduel is making your wild card weekend
even wilder why because the fanduel
sports book is hooking up new customers
with a 30 to one enhanced odds
uh opportunity this is uh you know you
make a deposit and you're getting a 30
to one enhanced odds opportunity that
means you can bet five bucks and win 150
bucks on any team to win any wild card
game i am not what one would call sports
savvy
but you know i follow basically through
my friends that are big enthusiasts and
i know this much
wild card weekend is already an exciting
time for sports fans and i like that
fanduel is taking it up a notch uh the
fact that wild card teams are often you
know the hotter teams in the league and
then there's the higher seeded teams
that are trying to stop their momentum
it's a cool kind of
it's just exciting i just i i even
somebody like me who i would even say is
sports illiterate can understand the
excitement of wildcard weekend and quite
frankly i do like to place a wager
which is
really why i like fanduel they are
america's number one sports book it's a
simple easy to use app they've got
generous promotions every day it's safe
and secure uh with the best in class
customer service these are all very
important things when you're dealing
with wagering right and when you win
fanduel will pay you your winnings in as
little to two hours that's almost as
good as sitting at a blackjack table in
a casino if you already have fanduel
sportsbook
fanduel is hooking up all customers with
fifty dollars when you refer a friend so
refer a friend and guess what they get
fifty dollars too
don't miss your chance to win 150 off a
five dollar bet when you use the promo
code taste buds when signing up
download the fanduel sportsbook app and
use promo code tastebuds pick your
wildcard team before the kickoff and
again if you're an existing customer
you're going to get 50
when you refer a friend and they will
get the same
fan dual america's number one sports
book 21 and over and present in arizona
colorado connecticut iowa illinois
indiana michigan new jersey pennsylvania
tennessee virginia or west virginia new
users only ten dollars first deposit
required must wager in designated offer
market max bonus 150
bonus for tennessee users fulfilled
insight credit within 72 hours tennessee
site credit expires 14 days after
receipt restrictions apply see full
terms at sportsbook.fanduel.com
gambling problem call 1-800 gambler or
visit fanduel.com rg colorado iowa
michigan new jersey pennsylvania
illinois virginia
call 1-800 next step or text next step
to 53342
arizona
call 888-789-7777
chat connecticut
1-800 9 with it in indiana
tennessee redline 1-800-889-9789
tennessee or visit www.1800gambler.net
in west virginia gee that's big the uh
so here's the thing
christmas
oh christmas was my favorite time of
year
until coveted kovid kind of robbed me of
the specialness of it because it made
covid made time not count anymore
yeah but you could apply that to any
holiday you can't discount christmas on
accountability for some reason my
birthday because it falls in the summer
probably
fell at a time both years now when i met
you in the summer where i was able to
have basically a normal birthday event
because it was summer and the numbers
were down and all that and you could sit
outside and it just felt
normal
christmas for two years now has not felt
normal yeah but you can't you got to go
i hear you i'm just saying the only
reason i feel that i could defend
birthdays over christmas at this right
now you've had a turn of a change of
heart yes because now i feel like it's
yeah but we're talking about the essence
of christmas what christmas is not what
your last two years experiences with
christmas well some people just want the
battle to be
some people some people would argue that
the spirit of christmas is giving
and the spirit of birthday is the
celebration of oneself i disagree with
that i think that the spirit of
christmas is giving and loving i think a
lot of it also too is the excitement of
what you'll be getting i think if any
person
gave a bunch of gifts out of christmas
and didn't get anything in return they'd
be kind of upset birthday birthday thing
i tell people every year when i have my
shindig
nobody's bringing a present nobody's
paying for i don't even get drinks
in fact
on my birthday last year i bought you
drinks and you got mad at me and you're
like it's your birthday and i'm like
we're not here for that we're here
didn't i override you no
i made you let me but i'm not saying you
didn't buy me drinks all night i'm just
saying like you let me buy it but i was
like but there was a time when i came
out i'm like and you're like you're not
paying for it i'm like dude i'm not here
to get free drinks i'm here to hang out
with my friends it's a good excuse for
everybody to come party together i don't
want to take away anything from your
current feelings on birthdays and
christmas but i feel like you're in a
vacuum and i thought this was going to
be a little bit more wider and broader
about christmas and birthday okay well
then let's take it to childhood level
what's better than your birthday
because because you're getting the
presents for of christmas but then also
everybody including all your friends and
whoever and and grown-ups are there
telling you you're the greatest person
in the world i i get that but you know
what for me
the lore
the steeped tradition
the community the communal stuff that
happens at christmas where nearly
worldwide because even if it's across
other holidays at that time of year
everybody
is in a mood together
in an idealistic way everybody's in the
christmas
spirit it's coin it's a coin phrase it's
got its own genre of music it's got its
own you you decorate your abode you you
you have special
dinners and and with friends and gift
giving exchanges and there is a magic to
it which we've discussed before you do
that on birthdays too for me christmas
as a kid is still more way more magical
than my birthday when i believed there's
nothing that yeah we spend the rest of
our lives chasing that feeling again you
killed kids and through friends yeah if
you're going to bring it if you're going
to bring it back to basic basics
obviously the belief that a jolly man is
bringing you pre you know of course
that's amazing there's there's literal
magic involved that's amazing but i will
say this i think everything you just
said is some is people do the same
here's where i would argue you
i think people's do the same things for
their birthdays that you just mentioned
you have dinners you have exchange
things you have whatever you have
celebratory things there's a lot of love
in the air it's very beautiful nobody's
fighting everybody wants to be a perfect
night all that stuff for what for your
birthday it's a one-way though baby but
no no no well i get to the one-way part
i get the one-way part but then the
beauty of it is you then do it for those
friends on the each of their respective
birthdays
so it is returned it's just not returned
on the same day okay it's like i owe you
yes now that said also what the beauty
of the birthday is is it has not been
turned into a shoving pushing
uh a crowded mall me me me crowded
holiday capitalist disgrace
and that's a big part of christmas a lot
of people
now hate christmas because of what it
represents on a capitalistic front well
i mean for me a lot of that [ __ ] is i
used to enjoy christmas shopping i never
did like there was three or four years
of my life i did black friday
and it was like it just happened to be
that it was the right time in my life
for me to enjoy it right but now i think
it's a horror show i hate it they don't
even do it anymore and now because of
the nature of
how busy i am or
me not wanting to be in public or covet
i actually do last many many many years
most of my shopping online which i also
despise yes it's more convenient but you
lose the act of the
going and actually physically searching
i did i do
keep to some actual brick and mortar
shopping i'll go to the christmas
markets and things like that but
the spirit is taken away when you're
just on
cyber monday i agree with you 100
and i'll say this new york living in new
york robbed me of the joy of christmas
shopping that's insane no no new york is
the epicenter i'll tell you why i'll
tell you why because none of my friends
or family that i buy for live in new
york okay so
it got and i didn't have a car until
recently so it got to this point where
it was like i had to order online and
have everything shipped to my mom's
house so i could then go there open
everything up from the boxes and wrap it
because i had no way to get it it's
become a drag it can be addressed it can
be and i never i couldn't and also too
there's no great mall in new york
there's no i mean the outdoor you know
there's plenty of brick and mortar but
there's something about going to a
suburban mall yeah
you're within a 30-minute drive of any
suburban mall in every direction i know
the the lack of the car really hurt me
over i missed the mall i haven't gone to
them all years i missed it so much [ __ ]
i know i say that why do we celebrate
birthdays the idea of celebrating the
date of your birth is a pagan tradition
pagans thought the evil spirits lurked
on days of major changes ooh i don't
need that in my head like the day you
turn a year older the ancient greeks
believed that each person had a spirit
that attended his or her birth and kept
watch
so that's pagan in the traditional sense
not the way it's been here's what i'm
saying for me for me
birthdays have always had um a yin yang
to it where it was like
you feel love
but
you also it's a birthdays have
inevitably have somber
moments to me every birthday because
it's also a i guess you could say this
for christmas too but birthdays is more
prevalent because you're marking an age
it's a reflective time it's a time for
like inventory and just self-reflection
and for me changing the passing of time
more so than not is a little bit um
depressing to me
you know it's just i i
love people and i love life and i love
that stuff and with every passing year
you you know if you want to think of it
in a way that's a little bit like
depressing of course it's like it's you
know that can be a part of it but i also
don't think that that's a bad thing i
think that's i think that's evolution
and i think that that's an important
thing and i think it i think you could
argue the same thing in the opposite
direction that christmas is throwing
blinders over or you know or or a filter
over you that everything is just perfect
and everything i don't care i'll take
that filter it's like cocaine and
coca-cola i'll take matrix okay with the
birthdays you like pills
how you feel about them over the years
when you're younger you're like oh i'm
16 and a half you know i can't wait till
i'm 21. oh my god that's the other thing
christmas never gives you a new thing
you're allowed to do yeah but hold on
okay that's true that's true that's a
good point but then somewhere along the
line you pump the brakes on your
birthday and you're like oh my god don't
even i'm not celebrating don't even ask
me my age i don't want to eat another
you to pass and then all of a sudden
birthdays for half your life birthdays
are cool for the other half you don't
even want them anymore i disagree with
that i think i think i think if you're
comfortable with life and you're
comfortable with age your birthday can
be an invigorating rebirth every year
where you're saying this is the next
phase we're moving on i think i
understand why getting older can be
depressing and i'm not saying it never
affects me
but i think that if you have the right
mentality and you're living a healthy
life you can welcome that you know
seinfeld said the 60s are his favorite
decade of life so far he enjoys every
decade more than the last throw me a
cool bill and every day that
follows the other day will be the best
day here's what i'm saying though
birthdays also
um
okay there's a there's a song an old
song it's my party and i'll cry if i
want to sure that's i think that's
referring to birthdays
i think i honestly believe like for a
birthday what about like birthdays also
presents no it's about the boy she liked
like
not coming to her party or about her
party was she just having a mixer
celebrating the birthday i mean you want
to throw birthday songs at me i'll throw
you happy birthday to you don't bring
stevie wonder into this
i mean you know
i'll go get my vinyl downstairs of a
very stevie one to christmas listen hold
on though go back to that
real quick
on the phones chloe points out and i got
it i got to speak to this because she's
absolutely right and i almost forgot to
say it
waiting for the moment joe derosa coyote
brings up birthday parties at mcdonald's
was there anything okay better fine than
your birthday party at mcdonald's
there's only one thing better i will
file that under a big check mark for
birthdays but one thing is still better
than that christmas every year
i here's what i look dude christmas
somehow found a way
outside of christmas people hate the
winter
january 1st on the winter is a barren
wasteland and it's depressing and it's
gray and it's cold and the snow becomes
black with grease and soap i agree and
but you know what perks set up it's
white it's powdery it's magical it's it
took the best
it made winter
not only amenable but like people what
else would make winter that if you had a
nice february birthday
nice february birthday get you through
the dark months what about the odds that
like
a lot of times a birthday presents the
quickest road to sadness what if you
don't have a party people forget your
birthday no one forgets christmas it's
impossible to forget you ever have
someone forget your birthday i it's been
it's midnight they didn't they didn't
some people okay don't go the other way
i had a party only half the people
showed up i'll go the other way with you
some people want you to forget their
birthday they don't want to think about
it some people cause some people because
why well because for whatever the reason
is but for some people want to forget
christmas but are obligated not to are
forced i think
people definitely we could say want to
forget their birthday at certain points
then what if we get christmas ever i've
been a lot i love christmas with all my
heart i know a lot of people that can't
stand it for all the planning and the
stress christmas
traditional dinner christmas traditional
confections and treats there's
drinks uh christmas drinks things
associated hot cocoa uh
feast of seven fishes things that you
bake around christmas you're going
narrow with the feast of the seven
fishes i love the food sure but you know
what i'm saying a big italian a big
dinner no matter who you are you're
having a big big dinner that doesn't
happen with birthdays i love big dinners
i love sitting around breaking bread
with family and friends i love thinking
of people wrapping their gifts and then
i get to pay off if i buy 20 people
gifts it pays off 20 times i get them to
open the gift i got see their reaction i
love that santa claus who is the
equivalent of santa claus yourself no
no
you buying something for your friend
because i'll tell you i'll tell you
there's nothing more rewarding
on somebody's birthday on a friend's
birthday
when you because you're not competing
with
piles of gifts you're competing with
about six maybe seven ten other people
and when you get the standout gift in
that group that feels great in christmas
no on your on somebody's birthday the
stairs oh you and you have given the
standard because you get a far less
amount of gifts on your birthday when
you give somebody at the party the
standout gift and you're like i hit the
home run this show but there is it's
hard to do that there are radio stations
that
stop their programming sure to only play
christmas music it's the only holiday
with a legitimate full genre of music
you have
legitimized musicians that do christmas
albums you have
to decorate the house we put trees
indoors
by the way the christmas light my
favorite thing in the world
hanging light i think christmas lights
should be on homes and businesses what
about streamers and balloons all the
class streamers and balloons
it's a bit much oh please i can handle
it once in a while that's crazy all
right we got to go to the phones we got
to go to the phones
we have to go to you can celebrate
christmas on the eve and the morning you
can celebrate christmas adult style and
then in the morning you celebrate a
kid's style
you know i mean i this christmas the
movies your childhood
sorry but your child's first birthday
your child's 10th birthday your child's
16th birthday there's a lot come on we
go your parents your parents 60th
birthday your your parents 75th first
i'll ask you this you could celebrate
christmas every year from now on we got
to go to the phone or your birthday
every year from now on and not christmas
what do you choose
birthday i choose christmas all right
well enjoy that as time continues to
mean nothing and you're robbed of all
holidays because you're not allowed to
go outside anymore all right
i'm seeing a lot of people write in that
their birthday is on christmas what do
you guys think of that oh i think you
got rob that's a real bummer my niece is
her birthday's on christmas it's a tough
one
uh christmas you can go outside and it's
very clearly a celebration to the rest
of the world your birthday is just like
any other day i agree uh anyone stuck
playing board games on christmas with
their family knows the correct answer is
your birthday also birthday cake takes
better than regular cake great point
christmas is just jesus's birthday what
am i why would i put that above my own
very funny i'm jewish so jesus's
birthday versus my real birthday isn't
much competition
uh birthdays don't have annoying music a
shame i don't worry about hearing a
dumbass break every so i'm gonna repeat
around my birthday and for me
he's not with mariah carey in that day
and i can't speak to that but she
doesn't consume all
songs if you prefer birthdays you hate
jesus
all right
where was the one about the fat guy
coming into his house he started to play
just the tip just for a minute 33 years
ago and now for 24 hours every year we
have to celebrate you for it
yeah
that one bothered me for some reason i'm
adopted maybe that's christmas
okay all right christmas is depressing
the older you get and too much pressure
buying gifts for people for my birthday
i only expect you to show up and get
litty titty
[Laughter]
that's the way i know if i've ever heard
that twitter that's the winner
titty pimp you're the young and have you
heard the term litty titty
that's the winner and also because he's
got no no where are you going
uh
also
right there pimp you just we're on
salsa windfall
one up one up pimpy
yeah
litty titty i don't know if that's a
mistake liddy titty is great no it's
fantastic all right bibian wins at
bibian cespedes uh
a n
c e s p e d e s that is our winner
follow that guy or girl
hashtag liddy teddy all right pimp take
us to the vote we got uh 11 000 votes
all right we broke eight thousand yeah i
like that here we go drum roll humble
pie babe segment
let's see these stats roll in
oh
wow
you know i thought christmas may have an
advantage i didn't think it'd be like
that do we have no jewish listeners at
all that i know that's crazy
that's with a jewish also uh
like a jewish advantage that was
actually a great argument you could have
made
even a lot of jewish people you know
celebrate christmas you could have
gotten that show i know many jewish
people celebrate christmas
look the points are in it's 71.8
christmas to 28.2 birthday i did not
think it would be that wide i thought
birthday was the best adversary for
christmas i think this may be amongst
some of the biggest margins we've ever
had i don't feel
too celebratory about it because
i gotta say the only thing i think that
could be christmas and i think we should
do this up we talked about in the past
you brought it up today i think we start
going back for a couple of rematches
here and there or take dominant people
and put them against other dominant
categories even if they don't mix and i
think we need to do christmas vs pizza
all right
all right i'm game fans let us know what
you think of that let us know your
thoughts on that in the comments please
subscribe to the show thank you for
subscribing we appreciate it i'm only
gonna plug one thing because we've
already plugged the dates joey roses
open now 174 rivington street please
come see us if you're in new york city
check
joeyrosesnyc.com for hours and info you
got anything i just want to start being
getting into the the habit of saying uh
you know please subscribe on youtube if
you don't follow us on spotify and
itunes it means a lot some of you may
not realize you might just go back each
week to listen but you don't know you
can hit that button and hitting that
button means a lot to us as well as you
know if you like it a good review um
that just helps with the algorithm and
the more that you guys are active on
those things like that we get pushed
forward and i just would like to say
like weekly that's something that can
really help us if you love the podcast
and want to see it grow even further
that's something you could do uh i'm on
tour check salvolcanocomedy.com although
i'm sure at the beginning of this we
dropped in our dates but uh that's why i
said that yeah yeah absolutely
i thought you said we did it during it
and i was like no i didn't i thought you
just don't maybe a knit hat was too
tight
all right well
i still love you babe still love you
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right